you ready I'm ready okay
stabou Lake Cab podcast boolecast show
special guest Tink thank you the very
talented thank you thank you so much
historically uh leveled talented person
like the levels of talent you possess is
historic thank you no I really
appreciate that yeah I think it's been
dope to just kind of witness like the
last few years the Run you've been going
on doing it independently yes sir
um
I've been a fanny for a very long time
so it's good to see you no thank you
like you said three years I've been
independent
it's a different vibe
how do you
do the ringer if you will you've had
like a long journey throughout the music
industry right you've been on the major
label side you've been working with
guys like Timberland guys like this guy
over here who has bad cigarette smoking
problem
AKA hit me
um but like for you like how how does it
feel to kind of like have a little bit
more freedom now and it feels like
you're doing a lot of stuff on your
turns now yeah that's what makes it fun
to be honest it feels like
I'm just being myself now yeah when I
was first like in the industry or in the
game it was a lot of label ads over my
situation
so you know I'm just getting back to
myself and really you know being
authentic again yeah with the music I'm
able to say what I want to say you know
work with who I want to work with yeah
it's just that freedom yeah for you like
I feel like when you first came out too
there was like kind of it was kind of
like a weird time to be like a female
artist who does like hip-hop slash r b
you're kind of like a hybrid artist
right and now I just feel like it's all
lining up for you how do you feel about
just kind of the landscape of Music in
2023 as opposed to when you first came
in obviously the industry's changed a
lot you know yeah it has
um
I feel like it's a it's more accepted
like you said back then it was kind of
I was like the
I don't want to say the only one doing
it but it was rare to hear like a rapper
you might have been the only one doing
it right I hate to say it like that but
maybe she was a female like Lauryn Hill
yeah so like in my generation I was the
only one doing it so it was you know it
was a um it took me a minute to really
you know just put put it out there um
but now it's honestly I feel like the
game is just more accepting yeah you
know we got like artists that are doing
like rock and rap you know I feel like
the the music the genres I blend in
together more and I think it's resulting
in better music too exactly people are
free
um yeah so yeah I think uh you know I've
always just done me I've never really
put a box put myself in a box right
but yeah it's working it's working out
for sure you've had some dope records
too uh thank you I'm glad you brought up
the wrap I think people forget that I
can really rap you could rap rap yeah I
can really rap I mean you've been on
your r b tip like some real ill r b
but sure you can rap that's I mean
that's what got me as a fan was like oh
this cooking she could bar out but she
also thank you but what's so crazy rap
is like so hard to really for me it's
really hard to like kick down the door
and rap right like the female the female
rappers you know it's just a different
ball game I feel like r b
people are more like receptive to my r b
songs when you first came out what year
was it like on a major label 2015. so
2015 the landscape of being a female
rapper quote unquote is way different
way different it was really loud Nikki
yeah and then Queen Nick and yeah shout
out to Nikki yeah and then there was uh
what 2015. wasn't a lot of female
rappers deje days love she was like
2014. you know but yeah it was
definitely tough because it and it kind
of there was like this female
Renaissance if you will around 2017 2018
where it was like and I I look at music
currently specifically hip-hop there's
like a lack of real records in rap right
now like if you really think about
like what has been the smash this year
that you go to the club and it's like
automatic like there's to play for
sure there's to play but
the days I just there's not like like
these dudes ain't making anthems no more
like at all like uh now glorilla is
making a Anthem you know what
I'm saying like I love me some glorella
like Megan's making real records you
know what I mean
um coil array the player's record
is a dope that's a hit that's a hit you
know what I mean I just feel like dudes
are just like kind of like women are
taking over to be honest I have I hear
more of the girls rapping than I do the
guys and they're making just better
songs absolutely and we we know our
audience too like you know women are
speaking for women so yeah you know do
you feel like uh you should have got
nominated for a Grammy
uh
I don't want to say that now I think you
know I'm really hard on myself I'm a
hard critic so I got a lot of work to
put in still right
um and like I say I'm really just
getting my foot in that door again yeah
so um with time and I don't really make
music to like be nominated nowhere I
feel like you know if it happens it
happens if it happens it happens and I'm
grateful
but um you know that's not like the end
all right for sure like so many artists
that never really got there yeah got
their Grammy or got their Awards but um
I mean Nas barely just won a Grammy last
year and it was like 20 25 years later
after him yeah
it's crazy yeah no so yeah